hallo leute willkommen zu einem neuen
video unserer super easy german reihe in
welcher wir euch jede woche ein neues
deutsches werk vorstellen
diese woche geht es um das werk sein los
geht's infiniti iv sein
sein oder nichtsein das ist hier die
frage
na ja lieber sein oder präsenz ich bin
du bist er sie es ist wir sind ihr seid
sie sind ich bin alina und wer bist du
ich bin so wie ich bin 22 jahre alt und
wie alt bist du
ich bin 20 jahre alt janosch ist
zufrieden
janosch ist beschäftigt
janosch ist nachdenklich janosch ist
aufgeregt
janosch ist müde
er will das super easy german team
bereit
janisch und sophie sind überrascht
wer ist da wir sind es sind alina und
sophie dritte ried um
ich war du warst er sie es war
wir waren ihr wart sie waren
ich glaube ich war schon mal hier
alina war wütend
wir waren froh dass der stress vorbei
war
hey leute er war echt super danke sie
toll gemacht
janisch und sophie waren überrascht
janisch und sophie waren nicht
begeistert
perfekt ich bin gewesen
du bist gewesen rss ist gewesen
wir sind gewesen ihr seid gewesen
sie sind gewesen letztes jahr bin ich an
der nordsee gewesen es ist sehr schön
gewesen
sophie ist den ganzen sommer lang in der
hängematte gewesen
wir sind heute sehr produktiv gewesen
ihr seid bestimmt auch fleißig gewesen
oder janisch und sophie sind spazieren
gewesen futur ich werde sein
du wirst sein rbs wird sein
wir werden sein ihr werdet sein
sie werden sein sprich mir nach ich
werde der beste sei
du wirst erstaunt sein wie schnell du
lernst kari wird begeistert sein
wir werden immer für euch da sein
ihr werdet in der lage sein euch mit uns
zu unterhalten
es wird einfach für euch sein
die leute werden beeindruckt von euch
sein ihr werdet stolz auf euch sein
konjunktiv 2 ich wäre
du wärst er sie es wäre hier wären ihr
wert sie wären
janosch wäre gern ein steinmetz von
beruf was wärst du gern von beruf ich
wäre glücklich wenn ich mehr zeit hätte
wir wären gerne lustiger wird schon was
sie können
wärt ihr bereit mit janosch angeln zu
gehen
sophie und alina werden überrascht wie
toll ihr schon deutsch spricht
das war unser super easy german video zu
dem verb sein wenn ihr jetzt euer
deutsch noch weiter trainieren möchtet
dann empfehlen wir euch unsere app zieht
lang auszuprobieren
dort haben wir unter anderem ein
vokabeltrainer mit dem ihr die
wichtigsten deutschen vokabeln üben
könnt bis bald
ich bin ein berliner ist der fokus immer
noch da weil ich sehe dass ich bin ein
berliner
ich bin ein berliner ich bin ein
ich bin ein berliner
ok